um so i don't think people understand
how important the role of a father is in
when it comes to raising a child yeah
between the ages of you know from birth
to eight um the child being raised my
mother is fine but then from that point
on especially when you have a son the
father plays such an important role in
that child's life 17 i think 70 percent
of people um um children born into you
know single parent households um that
are geared towards women so this is a
single mother their life is way way
worse than you know if it was in the
double parent household basically
fathers keep sons out of jail and those
over the poles some people say but it's
it's actually so crazy how important it
is yes when they're young fair enough
you know keeping them on but when they
get past a certain age again especially
with sons you kind of have to stop
leaving them with them with their moms
because especially when you have a son
you can't you know you can't really
discipline him as much because he's
stronger than you you know so you need
you need that testosterone to match